nord gegen süd ost gegen west der
eu-gipfel streitet noch immer über das
milliardenschwere corona hilfspaket
erst party dann randale auf dem
frankfurter opernplatz werden polizisten
aus der menge heraus angegriffen
hamilton auf der erfolgsspur
der formel 1 weltmeister gewinnt den
ungarn und übernimmt die gesamtführung
sebastian vettel wird sechster
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster willkommen bei unserem
heute nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag
mit juliane für den sport hallo genannt
zum eu-gipfel nach brüssel wo schon den
dritten tag über das corona hilfspaket
verhandelt wird doch die sache steht auf
der kippe
nach wie vor wollen die sogenannten
sparsam vier nicht akzeptieren dass
betroffene südländer viele hundert
milliarden an zuschüssen bekommen und
zwar ohne bedingungen
und dann gibt es noch polen und ungarn
die alles blockieren wollen wenn gelder
an ihre rechtsstaatlichkeit gekoppelt
werden über die verfahrene situation
glück weiter
seit heute früh ist es ein kommen und
gehen im brüsseler ratsgebäude hinter
den kulissen wird in unterschiedlicher
zusammensetzung hart gerungen um die
details des künftigen eu haushalts und
des corona hilfspakets die
selbsternannten sparsamen niederlande
österreich dänemark schweden und
finnland wollen das vom 750 milliarden
euro hilfspaket weniger als 400
milliarden als zuschüsse fließen
bundeskanzlerin merkel und
staatspräsident makro hingegen möchten
ein wuchtiges hilfsprogramm kompromisse
werden wir nicht auf kosten der
europäischen ambitionen eingehen das
sage ich ganz deutlich wir stehen hier
vor einer nie dagewesenen krise
gesundheitlich wirtschaftlich sozialen
existieren
die sparsamen fordern auch weiterhin
mitspracherecht der mitgliedstaaten bei
der kontrolle der hilfszahlungen
entweder man will als europäische union
dass das geld richtig eingesetzt wird
oder es soll versandten wenn es richtig
eingesetzt werden sollen da bietet dann
braucht es auch eine form der kontrolle
und ungarns regierungschef orban droht
seit tagen mit seinem veto den gipfel
platzen zu lassen falls weiter über eine
kopplung von eu-zahlungen an die
einhaltung rechtsstaatlicher normen
diskutiert wird für bundeskanzlerin
merkel steht gleich zu beginn der
deutschen eu ratspräsidentschaft hier
viel auf dem spiel
es gibt viel guten willen aber es gibt
auch viele positionen und so werde ich
mich mit dafür einsetzen aber es kann
auch sein dass es heute zu können
derzeit wird noch in kleinen gruppen
weiter verhandelt es könnte eine lange
nacht sitzung werden und sie tagen
weiter und weiter
wie kommt es denn dass man so gar nicht
vorankommt in brüssel stefan leifert ja
das hat damit zu tun dass der gipfel in
den letzten stunden zu einer richtigen
zerreiße und geduldsprobe geworden ist
das sieht man schon am zeitlichen ablauf
eigentlich hat das plenum also die runde
der 27 schon um 12 uhr also vor 6
stunden zusammen treten wollen das ist
immer noch nicht noch immer noch nicht
eingetreten wegen immer neuer kleiner
verhandlungs formate auch zweier
gespräche der streit der den gipfel hier
im kern blockiert ist nach wie vor der
zwischen dem norden der eu und dem rest
der eu es ist vor allem der niederländer
mark rutte der hier versucht milliarde
um milliarde den betrag an zuschüssen
der gewährt werden soll an corona
gebeutelte krisen länder wie italien zu
drücken ausgangspunkt waren ja mal 500
milliarden euro hinter den kulissen
redet man inzwischen über 350 375
milliarden euro
der streit wird weitergehen und auch der
ton ist sehr scharf geworden
hier ist von erpressung die rede sogar
von gegenseitigem hass also wenn hier
gleich die runde der 27 zusammentritt
dann gilt es vor allem zu entscheiden
macht es sinn weiterzumachen sind die
schnittmengen groß genug dann könnte das
hier eine lange nacht werden oder bricht
man ab und trifft sich in ein paar
wochen wieder
nun hat er deutschland die
ratspräsidentschaft inne kann denn die
kanzlerin in dieser situation ihr
politisches gewicht in die waagschale
werfen
sie ist natürlich hier so etwas wie die
chefs vermittlerin und als dienstälteste
der runde kennt natürlich auch keine die
befindlichkeiten der eu-mitgliedstaaten
so gut wie angela merkel dennoch dass
das hier so blockiert ist scheint wohl
auch daran zu liegen dass sie zwei
faktoren unterschätzt hat zum einen wie
sehr manche der regierungschef zu hause
von rechtspopulisten unter druck stehen
was ihnen dann hier wenig spielraum beim
gipfel lässt wie zum beispiel beim
niederländer mark rutte der im frühjahr
wahlen vor allem gegen rechtspopulisten
gewinnen muss und zweiter faktor ist
wohl dass es viel unmut gibt vor allem
bei den kleinen ländern der eu den sauer
aufstößt dass deutschland und frankreich
sehr dominant aufgetreten sind in den
letzten wochen vorschläge serviert haben
vor allem beim geld die die anderen
ihrem gefühl nach einfach abzunicken
haben das sind die befindlichkeiten die
sie wohl unterschätzt hat wenn der
gipfel ein erfolg wird
ist es auch ein erfolg angela merkels
wenn er scheitert ist es auch ein
scheitern der kanzlerin ja auch eine
lange nacht für sie wird das vielen dank
stefan leifert nach brüssel
eine bedrückende zahl zum corona virus
weltweit sind inzwischen mehr als
600.000 menschen in verbindung mit
kurbelt 19 gestorben
in deutschland bleiben die
neuinfektionen auf eher niedrigem niveau
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 390 menschen mit
corona infiziert der gleiche stand wie
gestern
und wieder hat sich das virus unter den
beschäftigten einer fleischfabrik
ausgebreitet 66 neue infektionen wurden
in einem geflügelschlachthof im
landkreis vechta festgestellt dort wird
für wiesenhof produziert 1000
mitarbeiter wurden getestet alle
infizierten und kontaktpersonen stehen
unter quarantäne
der betrieb läuft aber weiter auch
beschränkungen für die landkreise sind
nicht geplant
in vielen städten deutschlands haben
sich öffentliche plätze in letzter zeit
zu open air party zonen entwickelt meist
verläuft es friedlich anders in der
vergangenen nacht in frankfurt am main
tausende feiern auf dem opernplatz dann
brechen gewalttätige krawalle aus
polizisten werden verletzt dutzende
randalierer festgenommen
heiko pisa berichtet es ist offener hass
den beamten in der nacht entgegenschlägt
flaschen werden auf sie geworfen jeder
treffer von den knapp 500 leuten die
noch vor ort sind bejubelt auslöser war
eine schlägerei unter feinden als ein
mann zu boden geht schreitet die polizei
ein und wird selbst attackiert das ist
ein verhalten wie wir das in frankfurt
in dieser art und weise
den letzten wochen noch nicht
festgestellt haben das ist sozusagen der
traurige höhepunkt die bilanz am tag
danach 39 fest man bis auf eine frau
alles männer zwischen 17 und 21 jahren
und nach ersten erkenntnissen
überwiegend mit migrationshintergrund
acht von ihnen werden dem haftrichter
vorgeführt die frankfurter haben kein
verständnis für die angriffe das was
hier passiert oder auch an anderen
plätzen ich kann ihn dann noch andere
nennen es ist traue nach das muss man
einfach versuche zu unterbinden und
vielleicht mit viel kommunikation da
auch an die vernunft der leute
appellieren aber das ist inakzeptabel
warum muss das eskalieren oder brauchen
eine ausgangssperre ab 12 uhr
seit wochen beobachten die polizisten
dass sie immer öfter beschimpft
beleidigt und attackiert werden
das hat mit den rassismus vorwürfen zu
tun die dem rechtsextremismus vorwürfen
aber auch mit den vorwürfen zum thema
polizeigewalt was von den usa 1 1 nach
deutschland übertragen wurde
morgen setzten sich polizei und stadt
zusammen und diskutieren wie es künftig
an den wochenenden weitergehen soll
und jetzt zum zdf sommerinterview heute
mit bayerns ministerpräsidenten und csu
chef markus söder da ist ja eine frage
ganz besonders interessant die nach
einer möglichen kanzlerkandidatur
in der jüngsten umfrage des zdf
politbarometers liegt er da jedenfalls
ganz weit vorne
weniger über das sommerinterview und ein
politiker der sich in der korona
pandemie als macher und vorreiter
präsentiert
nürnberg blick von der kaiserburg diesen
ort hat sich markus söder für das zdf
sommerinterview ausgesucht urlaub könne
man hier und anderenorts machen die
eigentliche frage sei aber wie sicher
nur in urlaub machen kündigt weitere
corona testmöglichkeiten an
jedenfalls überlegen uns sitzung dann
ist auch machen dass wir uns in
flughäfen auch testzentren netz
einrichten dass wenn man das dem urlaub
zurückkommt sich auch dort jederzeit
kostenlos testen cabana jetzt werden wir
uns in bayern die ferien beginnen
verkehrsminister andreas scheuer gibt ja
quasi einen job versprechen in sachen
mode will der csu chef die ergebnisse
des untersuchungsausschusses abwarten
zweite chance auch für das durcheinander
bei der neuen straßenverkehrsordnung
schlecht gelaufen kann man sagen nicht
gut gelaufen
das muss man nochmal klären wie das
jetzt genau zustande gekommen ist wäre
an die scheuer hat jetzt die möglichkeit
ist noch mal zu erklären und und gut zu
machen auch horst seehofer bekommt
rückendeckung der innenminister hatte
eine studie zu rassismus bei der polizei
abgelehnt
die polizisten sind in deutschland wie
guten sie sorgen dafür dass wir
beschützt werden vor verbrechern
deswegen ist zunächst mal ganz wichtig
dass wir nicht nur polizei mit recht und
mit geld ausstatten sondern auch mit
vertrauen und dann ist da noch die frage
die in diesen tagen fehlt
kanzlerkandidat söder
ich habe immer gesagt mein platz ist
hier in bayern zum einen zum zweiten
glaube ich dass diese umfragen für jetzt
und film
die ist doch ganz klar dass die umfragen
im moment auch nur momentaufnahmen die
sieht ja geschuldet der aktuellen
situation markus so dass standard
antwort die ihn trotzdem viel offen
lässt das ganze sommerinterview mit
markus söder gibt es gleich nach den
heute nachrichten in syrien tobt seit
mehr als neun jahren ein erbitterter
krieg mitten in diesem chaos wählt das
land jetzt ein neues parlament
dabei steht die partei von machthaber
assad als sieger so gut wie fest ohnehin
ist die hälfte aller parlamentssitze für
sie reserviert es gibt aber auch keine
wirklichen oppositionskandidaten
kritiker nennen die wahl daher eine
fachs syrien macht derzeit eine schwere
wirtschaftskrise durch etwa 80 prozent
der bevölkerung leben in armut
zum sport schon da war heute wieder
lewis hamilton eine klasse für sich rudi
genau stellte alle in den schatten
weltmeister lewis hamilton gewinnt auch
den dritten lauf der formel 1 saison bei
seinem start ziel sieg auf dem
hungaroring vor den toren von budapest
überrundet er sogar sebastian vettel im
ferrari der wird am ende immerhin
sechster sein bestes saison ergebnis
mercedes ist mit weltmeister lewis
hamilton drückend überlegen in diesem
grand prix zum achten mal gewinnt der
engländer in ungarn max voß tappen im
red bull zerstört sich vor dem rennen
seiner aufhängung kann dennoch als
siebter starten und wird am ende zweiter
der niederländer mann des tages
sebastian vettel kommt auf rang vier zu
einem reifenwechsel hat aber zu viel
verkehr und direkt losfahren zu können
letztlich bleibt rang sechs mit einem
schwachen ferrari ich glaube dass wir da
nichts schlaues gemacht haben aber auch
nicht verkehrt ist und im endeffekt sind
wir damit geschwommen aber das war
natürlich irgendwo ein fenster wo man
hätte viel gutmachen können mit valtteri
bottas ein weiterer mercedes pilot auf
rang drei hamilton führt nun in der
fahrerwertung
der österreicher dominik team gewinnt
vier tage nach seinem erfolg auf dem
rasen des steffi graf stadions in berlin
auch das tennisturnier auf dem früheren
flughafen tempelhof
im finale setzt er sich gegen den
italiener ja nix in zwei sätzen durch
dominic thiem wurde seiner
favoritenrolle erneut gerecht der
weltranglistendritte gibt gegen yannick
sinne jederzeit den takt vor den ersten
satz gewinnt der österreicher mit 624
danach erhöht er weiterhin trug das
finale im hangar am flughafen tempelhof
ist eine einseitige angelegenheit nach
etwas mehr als einer stunde hat team
match ball und lässt dem erst 18
jährigen südtiroler beim 6 2 im zweiten
satz keine chance
mit seinen siegen in berlin zeigt er
sich gut gerüstet für den geplanten
neustart der tennis saison im august und
das war's schon vom sport petra danke
rudin bleibt uns noch der blick aufs
wetter im süden und an der nordsee
sonnig und trocken sonst mehr wolken mit
schauern und einzelnen gewittern 18 bis
32 grad
das war es von uns für tina schausten
begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn im heute
journal
wir sind morgen wieder für sie da und
jetzt wünschen wir ihnen noch einen
entspannten sonntagabend